hi everybody I'm Britney Lewis with
Forbes breaking news joining me now is
Kristen Stoler a senior editor covering
the Forbes 30 under 30 lists Kristen
thank you so much for joining me of
course thanks for having me brinnie
first of all I going to extend a big
congratulations the 2024 Forbes 30 under
30 list has officially dropped I know
how big of an undertaking that must be
yes it just feels like a giant you know
weight off my shoulders and like I gave
birth to a baby so I am thrilled that
it's live so let's just start from the
beginning here let's talk about
logistics how do the under 30s get
chosen so there's a lot so we it's
pretty much a whole year round process
um so we open up our nominations for
this North America list in the spring
this year I believe it was around March
or April uh we got 11,000 people who
applied for just the North America list
itself so our reporters I have a team of
54 reporters who work on this list with
me for all 20 categories and we read
every single application we look through
them we vet these people sometimes we'll
reach out with a phone call sometimes in
email um and that's one way we're
getting candidates the other way is for
with uh good old-fashioned reporting so
we're scouting year round for people in
our beats who we think are the best and
brightest in their categories we're
talking to our sources analysts um and
doing some reporting that way so it's a
mix of both people applying or being
nominated by a friend family member or
colleague and then also our own scouting
and Reporting and let's talk about how
you're whittling this down not only you
but judges too so it goes from over
11,000 to 600 entities describe that
process yes so we have a team of four
expert judges for each category three or
four depending on the category um and
these are people who are the top people
in each of the industry Industries they
represent you know we've had everyone
from Taylor Swift be a judge we've had
Tory bur be a judge so people who are a
in their field of course thee exactly um
so we as reporters take a look at that
11,000 we try and narrow it down to Who
We Believe are the top about a 100 to
hand off to the judges and then from
there the judges then score that roughly
a 100 people and give their scores back
to us um but we're really looking at
because it's Forbes we're looking at the
financials so we're looking at funding
Revenue we're looking at valuation who
people's investors are um what their
revenue model is if they have a solid
idea that's never been done before if
there's the potential to scale so things
like that are top of mind for us and you
mentioned there are 20 categories can
you go through the different categories
of it for us absolutely so we have
everything from the more creative side
of things which is Music Entertainment
social media with our creators um Sports
which is a big category and games we
have orts too um art and style is a big
one and then we have you know the
finance the venture capital the tech
consumer and Enterprise um food and
drink marketing and advertising media
and I science Health Care it really runs
the gamut we have 20 of them so I
encourage everyone to look online and
read all of them but those are just some
of the top top ones I can think of the
list continues to be inspiring year over
year over year what are some of the
inspiring stories this year does
anything stick out to you oh yes there
is one story that I love um Raja who is
our social impact call out with her
co-founder Ry they co-founded this
company called invis aware and it came
from when one of the co-founders was in
college she had a very scary experience
that a lot of women have which is she
was being catall late at night walking
home from a class uh one of the men got
out of the car and she got very scared
and just ran all the way back to her
house and from there she was kind of
inspired to rethink the 911 call and
rethink you know how women can feel
safer at night and just when you know
pretty much in any setting so she teamed
up with one of her friends from college
Ray to create this jewelry which is
called invis aware and it's like a
little button about that big either on a
necklace or on a keychain or on a
bracelet or a watch and if you double
tap it it'll connect you with an ADT
Security and then from there you have
the option to call 911 so they I think
they did about 6 million in Revenue last
year and it's taken off so that's one of
my favorite stories she's one of our big
call outs this year on the social impact
list that's incredible and that's a
story many women many girls can relate
to absolutely I do now want to Pivot a
little bit and you actually broke the
list down by some numbers yes what are
some of those stats give us a taste of
that I absolutely can okay so the first
is the total funding raised by all of
our people on the list is 3.6 billion
this year and interestingly enough that
is down from last year last year it was
at 5 billion and I think just people
were getting there was so much funding
floating around after the pandemic and
now it's finally come back to normal and
is that a normal number now that in the
three billion neighborhood that's pretty
normal based on what we've had pre
pandemic um the youngest person on our
list this year is 15 years old if you
can believe it so the average age that
we have on the list is
27 um this year we reached an alltime
high with gender parity which I am
thrilled about uh we have 42% of people
on the list identify as female 1%
non-binary and 57% male that's
incredible love to hear more women's
Stories being highlighted another number
that you pulled I found very interesting
was the average amount of hours per week
worked yes what does that look like 66
hours per week these listers work on
average which is up from last year last
year it was 64 hours a week so sadly
putting in the time I know don't like to
hear that you know not at all a lot more
time but getting great results being on
the list and when you boil down the list
this way by the stats what is surprising
to you I think the most surprising thing
to me is well I guess this shouldn't be
too surprising but obviously this is the
greatest number of gen Z that we've ever
had and we're starting to get more of
genen alpha too especially with you know
the youngest being 15 that was super
surprising um the number of immigrants
has always stayed pretty much the same
this year you have 23% of people on the
list are immigrants and uh 43%
self-identify as people of color which
is really exciting um so that's those
have been some interesting surprising
things for me I do want to talk about
gen z a little bit because as
Millennials start to age out become over
30 you're seeing more geny on the list
as you said so what is the difference
that you're seeing between the geny
generation perhaps the Gen Alpha
generation from Millennials I think for
me and as a millennial member would
which has been really I've learned so
much from jeny I continue to every day
yeah I think it's that they are not
afraid to really put themselves out
there and promote themselves whereas I
think for us Millennials it's like take
what you're given like be humble do this
they're in a great way like really
promoting themselves and pumping
themselves up and saying like here's why
I'm awesome here's why you should
consider me and they really reach out in
a way that I feel like Millennials are
sometimes scared to and I love that I
want to channel that energy all the time
I do think in the difference I've seen
is that they are more self assured where
our generation definitely has a lot of
self-doubt 100% And I'm working on it
and Jen's inspiring me so oh absolutely
and you and I had this same conversation
last year so I'm curious how this year
is shaping up to be different than last
year's list this year we are seeing a
lot of AI and that's like the big buzz
word right now but I feel like all
almost I'd say a good majority of the
applications mentioned AI in some way um
we have you know on our marketing list
um the our big call out there who did
the photo shoot with us is um with this
company called Tavis and they are using
AI to change the face of marketing which
is really interesting because you don't
really feel that way about marketing and
and advertising but they're doing this
thing where you as you know a company
like a a Salesforce or a meta can record
a video of yourself and then using AI
it'll clone the video hundreds of times
and put in a different word or phrase or
person so if you're pitching a client or
saying it'll like put in their name
instead of it using AI so that's been
cool um we have ai for insurance AI bot
selling insurance which is really
interesting so that's been a big theme
this year that I feel like has been
quieter in previous years and I'm I am
curious about what this does to a
person's personal brand because we're
seeing like we do every year the under
30 list go massively viral you can't go
on Instagram the day of the launch day
go on Twitter it's automatically
trending you see who's a new under 30
what does this do for your personal
brand I can only speak anecdotally from
what our community members have told me
but I feel like for a lot of them it
helps a with funding they are able to
get conversations with Venture
capitalists and other people that they
might not have been able to before so I
think that is a big get for them um the
other is just the sense of community so
when you make the under 30 list you're
then part of our under 30 Community we
have um internal slack groups and other
systems where they can communicate and a
lot of under 30s find each other
collaborate with each other and then
come up with business ideas or you know
buy each other's companies out or merge
and things like that so that I think is
part of the magic of being on the under
30 for these people Forbes had it first
it's been duplicated many times the
under 30s myma does a under 30 Temple
University the the first uh Professional
Event I've ever been to fresh out of
college I actually went to the under 30
event in Philadelphia I was not a Lister
I was just just there for fun so this
really resonates with people under 30
and general why do you think that is I
think it's just you know it's part of
like it's an achievement like any
achievement you know it's like everyone
wants to feel a sense of accomplishment
and like they've done something great
and the business they've created is
great but I think it's I think it's
again goes back to the community aspect
it's like you are in such good company
you're with Rihanna you're with Malala
youf you're with all of these really
inspirational people and you're in good
company so I think being part of that
group is you know a validator it shows
that you've done something incredible
and you've changed the world or your
industry um and I think that's really
important to people and I know that this
will be hard but if you could boil down
this this year's list into one word one
characteristic that all of these under
30s embody what is that word this year
for me I think it's grit we're seeing
people coming out of the pandemic coming
out of War coming out of all this
negative stuff that's been going on and
still finding a way to move forward and
keep building and do better than
previous years Kristen Stoler once again
big congrats to you everyone check out
the list it is out now thank you so much
for joining me
Britney